[Music]
foreign
good morning this is inking live and our
business and economic news from the
Heart of the City of shares of Microsoft
searched by more than eight percent in
after-hour trading last night after the
software giant reported sales and
earnings for the first three months of
the year that were significantly better
than expected Microsoft reported sales
of 52.9 billion dollars for the three
months to the end of March that was up
seven percent on the same period last
year and almost two billion dollars
better than expected well that was
driven largely by strong growth and
Azure its Cloud business ourselves were
up 27 on a constant currency basis
Microsoft's earnings during the quarter
Rose by 9 to 18.3 billion dollars
meanwhile alphabets the parent of Google
also reported better than expected sales
and earnings for the quarter well
joining me now live from San Francisco
is our old friend Dan Ives he's managing
director and Senior equity research
analyst at woodbush Securities Dan good
to see you this morning thanks for
joining me at such an unsociable hour
looking at your notes overnight you
clearly loved Microsoft's results but is
it fair to say that expectations were a
little depressed going into these
results
yeah look I mean clearly caution going
into actual earnings but I think if you
look I I mean this was a flux the
muscles moment for big Tech I think
Microsoft really shown that Enterprise
are continuing to spend on the shift to
cloud and we're seeing that with Google
as well and that's great news for
investors that have been fearing Tech
earnings and I think this continues to
be a green light for tech stocks now
looking at Azure in particular up 27 in
the quarter on a constant currency basis
that was actually slower than it has
been growing at is that something people
should worry about
yeah well it's slowing obviously in a
shake your macro and you've seen some
Enterprises you know obviously soften
spend but this is better than expected I
think you know what I'll call right now
they're gaining share in their
Enterprise backyard versus Amazon ews
and I think ultimately Microsoft from
Cloud to AI is really on the offensive
and I think it speaks to this is a stock
that continues to move higher absolutely
you mentioned AI they're obviously much
excitement about Microsoft's investment
in chat GPT what did we learn last night
from what the management was saying
yeah I think from the Della this is
really sort of opening the the covers on
the AI strategy showing that
monetization is now actually starting to
play out in AI look this is a Game of
Thrones going on in terms of AI not just
Microsoft Google and obviously every
other Tech player and I think this is
something that Microsoft's showing that
they're going to continue to monetize
still early days and that's going to be
a key takeaway today I mean it's
interesting isn't it with everyone's
excited about the prospects for Bing on
the back of uh chat GPT but it's
actually co-pilot which is uh integrated
into the uh office suite that
potentially offers the more exciting
growth would you say
oh yeah I think ultimately that is
multitudes more in terms of office
Enterprise how they can monetize rather
than just search and I think for Nadella
they've sort of cracked the code here in
Ai and that's why it's really causing AI
arms race but if you look at Cloud you
look at AI right now Microsoft really
going 85 miles you know in terms of the
left lane versus where I think a lot of
other Tech players are sort of playing
the defensive to some extent Microsoft's
on the offensive
and we're turning that to uh alphabet uh
obviously ad spend was uh easing us was
expected but again they they surprised
the market
yeah I think digital advertising you're
seeing some stabilization and we hear
from meta as well that's important
because that's as big of a barometer
that you get from digital advertising
YouTube That's the golden Jewel which
would definitely seen success there and
then Cloud I mean gcp for Google they're
gaming in cloud and this I think is
something that's still under you know
estimated by the street in terms of what
Google's doing in Cloud very very
important especially in this type of
environment
they mentioned last night that they're
raising uh their capex uh over the
coming quarters is a lot of that going
to be on cloud-based activity
it is uh you know between that as well
as AI because Google they're trying to
choose Microsoft not just on AI but on
cloud and that's music to the ears of
investors you want to see these tax
dollars increasing cat-backs you know
given an environment that's clearly not
roses and champagne and overall that's a
part of any investor has slept a lot
better last night in terms of these Tech
earnings you mentioned uh you said this
is a bit of a Game of Thrones moment in
AI right now clearly Microsoft are ahead
how do you rate the chances of of
alphabet and others closing the gap on
them
yeah alphabet I mean they have some
probably the best Engineers from the AI
developer perspective in the world and
then also don't forget about it and what
I'll call Apple in terms of what they're
gonna do over the next called few years
I think they could spend numbers of
eight to ten billion then you have
Amazon as well you have other Tech
players playing now and I think this is
we view as an 800 billion dollar market
opportunity right now it's Microsoft
Google but I think this is really going
to be something that plays out over the
coming years
all right Dan we've got to leave it
there thanks again for joining me at
such an unsung good to see you take care
some other stories for you now and the
drug maker GSK has hailed strong sales
of its Blockbuster shingles treatment
shingrix after reporting better than
expected quarterly results while
operating profits for the first three
months of the year on an adjusted basis
came in at 2.1 billion pounds that was
unchanged from the same period last year
despite a hit from lower covid related
sales well sales stripping out covered
Solutions were up 10 to 6.8 billion
pounds day member Warmsley gsk's chief
executive said the company enjoyed an
excellent performance across each of its
divisions vaccines specialty and general
medicines
the house Builder persimmon said this
morning that it was seeing early signs
of increasing customer confidence which
were particularly evident in demand for
its three four and five bedroom homes
the UK's fourth largest house Builder by
stock market value said it completed
1136 homes during the first three months
of the year that was down 42 percent on
those months last year but as expected
given the challenging trading
environment in the second half of 2022
but Dean Finch the chief executive said
in recent weeks the company had seen
visitor numbers up cancellation levels
normalizing and sales rates continuing
the steady Improvement evident since the
beginning of the year
the household goods giant racket Ben
Keiser is promoting the head of its
Health business to become its new chief
executive Chris Licht who's also records
Chief customer officer will take control
on the 1st of June well the news came as
wreck it whose Brands include Mr Sheen
Calgon silit bang Dettol and nurofen
reported sales of 3.9 billion pounds for
the first three months of the year that
was ahead by 7.9 percent on the same
period a year ago on a like-for-like
basis
and some breaking news for you and in
the last hour it's been announcer so win
Bischoff one of the city's best known
and influential figures over the last
five decades has died so when who was 81
was chairman of Lloyd's banking group
from 2009 to 2014 and helped support its
Rehabilitation following the global
financial crisis before that he enjoyed
a distinguished career at Schroeder's
now the UK's biggest quoted asset
management but which was previously one
of the biggest and most important
British owned investment Banks to win
was chief executive of Schroeders from
1984 to 1995 when he became chairman
later overseeing the sale of the group's
Investment Banking division to the Wall
Street giant City whose European arm he
later chaired for seven years
now the government is being urged to
develop a strategy to help farmers
convert millions of tons of cow dung
into biogas which can be pumped into the
power grid the former owned Dairy joined
Allah the company behind Brands such as
Craven dough milk and Tall Valley Cheese
says more than 100 million tons of
manure slurry and food waste is produced
by British Farms each year and has the
potential to be turned into enough
biomethane to fuel 6.4 million homes
will joining me now to talk about this
is James Perry he's vice president for
planning and Logistics at Harlow James
welcome to you without getting to uh
technical on me how does the conversion
process work
foreign
process works through a process called
anaerobic digestion and that is a
process through the absence of oxygen
and the tanks that have the absence of
oxygen that trigger that process are
called anaerobic digesters and that is
the process to convert organic matter
into energy
and does that process involve the the
use of fossil fuels in any way such as
Natural Gas
yeah so what Allah which is the UK's
largest area Cooperative is is calling
for support from the government to
support Farmers further utilize
renewable energy sources such as biogas
which in turn will support the UK's
energy Independence and energy security
so biogas is a huge untapped opportunity
where we can convert organic matter into
a renewable energy resource well we'll
get into the numbers in a minute but uh
what about the uses of biomethane what
primarily would it be used for
at the moment we the the opportunity
here is you talk about the amount of
waste that's produced at the moment
within this country and for context
within the livestock industry of which
Arla farmers are part of that industry
we produce about 91 million tons of
organic waste whether it's cow slurry or
manure and another 10 10 tons of
finished goods waste the untapped
potential of that if we had the
infrastructure and support network to
convert that into energy the opportunity
is to power Circa 6.4 million homes
within the UK
so you've said you want government
support I presume that's largely with
equipping uh Farms with these anaerobic
digestives
we're asking for the government for
support the first is a nationwide
anaerobic digestion strategy both at a
centralized community and at Farm level
and the second is the recognition for
more accessible and costly connections
to the grid that allows Farmers to tap
into solar power as another renewable
energy resource what sort of costs are
we talking about then
it's a very difficult it's a very
difficult question to answer uh what
today and last week was all about was
highlighting the untapped potential
and for another data point you know we
produce about 170 million tons of
organic waste each year within the UK
at the moment we use about a quarter of
that waste if we had the network and
infrastructure to unlock all of the
energy for 170 million tons of waste the
opportunity is 27 million tons of CO2
reduction or the equivalent of planting
450 million trees
would there be much expense involved in
converting the gas transmission system
presumably the grid is going to have to
uh be altered in some way to carry this
sort of gas alongside the existing gases
it carries
without doubt there will be a cost to
this transition
but what last week and today is all
about is highlighting the untapped
potential that we have at this moment in
time we we live and we work in a world
of resource scarcity and what today is
all about is highlighting to the
government a huge untapped opportunity
in converting the waste that we
currently generate into a renewable
energy resource okay James got to leave
it there appreciate you joining me today
thank you thank you very much
[Music]
time now for a look at this morning's
business pages and the financial times
leads its print edition with President
Biden's formal launch of his campaign
for re-election the ft is currently
leading its online editions with the
shop sell-off yesterday in shares of the
california-based lender First Republic
which sank by more than 49 after
reporting that its customers had
withdrawn 100 billion dollars worth of
deposits during last month's turmoil in
the banking sector well the times leads
its business pages with news at British
American Tobacco has agreed to pay 635
million dollars to U.S authorities over
alleged sanctions busting in North Korea
stretching back a decade the paper also
covers yesterday's report from the
Public Accounts committee which found
that out of an estimated 2.2 billion
pounds lost to fraud and error in
pandemic Grant and Loan schemes only 10
million pounds has so far been recovered
meanwhile The Daily Telegraph leads with
analysis suggesting that the UK will
miss out on 3 billion pounds worth of
tourists spending this year as a result
of Rishi sunak's decision when
Chancellor to abolish that free shopping
for visitors to the UK the telegraph
suggests it is why spending by tourists
in the UK has yet to recover to
pre-pandemic levels while it has in
other European countries most notably
France joining me to discuss all of that
is Artie nachiapa and she's the
economics correspondent at the Times
Arty good to see you this morning before
we talk about anything else we've got to
address these comments from uh Hugh pill
the bank's uh Chief Economist uh
overnight I'm just going to play your
viewers a little extra to what he said
so somehow in the UK someone needs to
accept that they're worse off and stop
trying to maintain their real spending
Power by bidding out prices whether
higher wages or passing the energy costs
through onto customers Etc and what
we're facing now is that that reluctance
to accept that yes we're all worse off
and we all have to take our share
I'm a naughty uh those comments have
attracted a lot of interest it's the
front page of the Daily Mail which has
got itself into a right lather about it
uh is he a bit tone deaf or has he got a
point
I think the issue here is that you can't
have any economics without politics and
it's reminiscent of the comments that
Bailey made and there's the same problem
there is that it ignores all of the
context in which people are living in
the kind of lack of real wage growth
that we've seen since the financial
crisis and to tell people now that they
kind of have to accept being poorer
there are so many problems with the way
that that comes across I think also the
fact that we're dealing with a crisis of
Essentials at the moment so it's food
and energy that are really pushing up
household bills and if you're a poorer
household that's going to hit you more
than um than a than a you know a wealthy
Central Bankers household so I think
it's being told that you have to take
your share well that share is a lot more
painful for a lot of the people that
Hugh Pearl is talking to
um then it might be for people himself I
know that's not a personal thing but if
you separate economics from the politics
and you kind of talk about it in an
economic theory way of okay well if
everyone in theory
um seeks to increase pay or puts up
prices in an effort to maintain profit
margins then yes you're right that info
Nation will continue to rise but is
inflation the only Target or are we
looking at the economy as a whole
obviously he's a central Banker so he's
talking about inflation but I just think
when you look at these context comments
in isolation and there isn't any kind of
understanding of what people are dealing
with then they just don't have the
impact that that he's trying to have
one thing that's dropped me is quite
interesting though Arty is that he's
whilst everyone's delighted on what he's
saying about households he did also say
that businesses need to stop bolstering
their profit margins and passing on
higher costs to Consumers and that's
exactly what some of the trade unions
have been saying
yeah it's very true and it is important
to highlight both sides of the coin
because that is the spiral that people
are concerned about and so I think that
that was and that's what Bailey when he
came under Fire for his comments tried
to highlight that it's also price
setting it's not just the wages it's the
back and forth response and I do think
that maybe should be more of the focus
absolutely well let's talk about some of
the stories you've picked this morning
and not obviously all of the papers
including your own the times has gone on
the public borrowing figures yesterday
yeah I think this is interesting because
we were saying after the obr forecast
came out that Jeremy Hunt has the
smallest a wafer thin margin of Headroom
to be able to meet his targets after the
measures that he announced in March it's
actually the thinnest of any Chancellor
since the establishment of the obr in
2010 and now this gives him a little bit
more wiggle room so public borrowing on
balance has come in less than expected
for the OB compared to what the OVR
expected for the last year and so this
means that Jeremy Aunt has a little bit
more space to either increase spending
or cut taxes but if you look at the
reasons why it was a little bit lower
it's mainly because of higher tax
receipts and attacks that grew the most
was the at mainly because prices that
the tail have been going up so much
because of inflation so it does feel a
little bit like inflation is feeding
through into all areas of of the
government's finances and this is one in
which it has benefited a little bit in
the sense that they've got the
opportunity now to be able to ease the
burden a little bit where they choose to
do it yeah it'd be interesting to see
what they do with that weren't it now
what about the Public Accounts committee
I mean again it's a story covered uh
pretty widely this morning
I think what was interesting about this
is that we're talking about a department
that is currently in the process of
being disbanded in its function siphoned
off to other government departments and
I think the concern for me would be is
if a lot of these failings failing to
recover money lost in foreign error some
10 million was recovered of 2 billion
2.2 billion even lost I think if that is
then all put down to this department
that is being disbanded and there's a
lack of accountability I think there
could be a real issue that the lessons
that need to be learned are not but
equally you could also see it in the
sense that this department wasn't really
functioning as it was supposed to and it
is the right time for a re-jig but as we
we know that's often always a way of
passing the buck
hahaha very good point so what do you
think then personally about uh the the
business department do you think they
are accountable for for these
shortcomings or is it just a more
General malaise within Whitehall
I think it's difficult I definitely
think culture comes into it and um once
you've got so much bureaucracy
a lot it's very easy to say it wasn't
you know it wasn't us that this
responsibility lay here
um but I do think that there have been
issues with the department and I just
wonder whether it's coincidental the
timing that we have for a rethink of it
yeah very good point you make oh so
you've got to leave it there good to see
you this morning thank you
and a reminder to check out the Ian King
live podcast which you can find by
scanning the QR code on your screen
right now that's available now wherever
you get your podcasts including the Sky
News app Apple and Google podcast and
Spotify
well still to come here on Ian King live
we're gonna have a look at how the
markets are doing this Wednesday morning
don't go away
[Music]
thank you
foreign
there's always more to the news than a
headline we want to discover to delve a
little deeper to find out what's really
going on explanation analysis the people
at the heart of every story I'm Neil
Patterson and this is this guy News
Daily podcast Alex Crawford joining us
now from Ukraine their personal
possessions are all scattered around the
place our economics and data editor Ed
cordaway try him extensive at the big
numbers for us things can change
incredibly quickly that's what they have
done so by the end we'll hopefully all
understand what's going on in the world
just that little better available
whatever you get your podcast
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back sorry for the uh slight uh
interference so we've had a few
technical Gremlins creeping in but
someone's put another Shilling in the
meter and we're back and raring to go
again so let me take you without further
Ado on to the market so I'm going to
stop with the currencies the pound is
higher against the US dollar this
morning thank you Bill's comments
overnight might have been digested by a
few people Sterling up half a one
percent right now against the dollar
they're also pissing me a bit of dollar
weakness though because uh uh the euro
is up two-thirds one percent against the
Greenback as well on the equity markets
well following last night's sell-off on
Wall Street is concerns revived over the
health of some U.S Regional lenders
there was mixed trading in the Asia
Pacific region overnight the Nikka in
Tokyo which on Tuesday hit an
eight-month High fell by nearly three
quarters of one percent while Hong Kong
rallied by a similar amount Sydney
Mumbai and Shanghai were more or less
all unchanged well in Europe stocks have
been largely trading to the downside so
far this morning all of the main
European indices in negative territory
right now it's a busy day for company
results among the talking points in
Europe this morning the German
sportswear maker is off two and three
quarter percent following a downbeat
Outlook statement well here in London
the ftse 100 is also in negative
territory right now uh currently off a
third of one percent I think some of the
big dollar heavyweight earners are
weighing on the index this morning
including the healthcare Giants in
percentage terms the biggest blue chip
Faller for the second consecutive day is
associated British Foods that's
currently off five percent that was
after its trading update yesterday it
was about six percent off I think at one
point yesterday among the gainers will
persimmon mention them earlier on in the
program they're leading gainers and the
likes of Taylor wimping Barrett
developments are up in sympathy outside
the ftse 100 the power generator Drax is
ahead by more than uh four percent and
that is after it announced a 150 million
pound share buyback program as for the
oil price well there was a drop in U.S
Crim crude inventories yesterday and
that supported the price a barrel of
Brent crude will currently set you back
80. 98 cents a barrel that is up a
little over a quarter of one percent
were joined me this morning is Rachel
winter she's a partner at killer conco
Rachel good to see you this morning um I
mentioned rackets latest results are in
the program seem to have gone down quite
well they do but I think the big
surprise here is the new chief executive
and so we have had an internal hire
being promoted to the chief executive I
think that is a bit of a surprise
because it's taken seven months for
record to appoint the new chief
executive and because it was taking so
long I think people assume there would
be an external hire that isn't the case
but I think the good thing about having
someone internal is that you will have
more continuity yeah so and it's always
good for morale isn't it when someone
comes from inside the business to take
over the running it is I think it's
quite inspiring for people who are
working there already yeah now what
about persimmon I mean it's been a bit
of a Taylor woe from the builders over
the last six months but glimmer of hope
here yeah so the big headline from them
this morning is that completions were
down 42 between the first quarter of
this year and the first quarter of last
year but if you look at some of the
comments from the chief executive he had
said that confidence seems to be
returning they've seen quite a big drop
in cancellations which is good and they
do seem to be having more people coming
to look at their properties so it does
feel as though things are on the up and
I think those comments have sent the
shares up this morning yeah it kind of
feels in keeping with what we've heard
in terms of the secondary market right
now from the likes of right move over
recent days it does indeed and I think
that's because it's because coming
easier to find a mortgage I think if we
go back to September post many budget it
was very difficult for many people to
get a mortgage now there are more Banks
offering mortgages and I think that has
brought some confidence back to the
housing market yeah now one we haven't
talked about this morning is Standard
Chartered share price hasn't really
moved although the results weren't
themselves too bad I didn't think I
thought they were good so they've had a
big increase in interest income because
interest rates have gone up so much but
I think with banks what people are
really looking at is deposits we're
really Keen not to see any deposit
outflows because that's been the big
issue for banks like Silicon Valley
Credit Swiss and also First Republic
Banks so the good thing about Standard
Chartered is that deposits have remained
fairly constant and that shows that
people are reasonably confident in the
bank at the moment now obviously we hear
from the other UK lenders over the next
few days and not really that much of a
read across I guess from Standard
Charter to the likes of Barclays and
Lloyds no I think Standard Chartered is
quite different because it's so exposed
to Asia which I think in the past has
been a good thing but it's so exposed to
China that I I think some people are
becoming concerned about that yeah I
mean we had Santander reporting
yesterday getting the UK arm did okay I
mean the stock price I noticed was lower
in Madrid yesterday yeah I think I feel
quite comfortable with UK banks at the
moment I think because interest rates
have gone up here so much I think banks
are doing well I think the regulatory
environment here is very strong and
that's good for banks but that's not the
case that some overseas Banks is which
is why there is some concern about the
sector elsewhere yeah now the biggest
company reporting in the UK today of
course is GSK which we mentioned uh
earlier on in the program again I mean
this company feels like it's turned a
corner after a few years of trivials it
does so good results this morning I
think revenues were up quite strongly
they've reaffirmed their guidance for
this year and their dividend dividend as
well so that's good news for investors I
think here investors really want to see
some more big new blockbuster products
but GSK really is focusing on that they
have got a number of small Acquisitions
going through so they really are on the
search for a bigger new drug at the
moment yeah I mean looking at the
statement I think they said they've got
something like 6 68 drugs under
development in the pipeline I mean
that's pretty Punchy for even for a
business of this size it is it's a very
big number so let's hope that at least a
few of those do you go through to become
Blockbusters How concerned would you be
about uh the dollar into I mean
obviously gsk's main Market is the us a
lot of their earnings are in dollars
it's always quite interesting to see the
pan moving against the Greenback on a
day like this and GSK coming off this
bike good results yeah yeah I think
investors like the fact that so much of
the revenue is in dollars I think people
feel more comfortable with dollars at
the moment versus Sterling I think there
is still some concern about Sterling
post-brexit so I think I like the fact
that there is so much dollar exposure
there okay now you've also uh your eyes
been caught by Heathrow today
big increase in past
differently back to being the number one
busiest airport in Europe but despite
that the company has made a loss and it
won't be paying a dividend this year the
amount they can charge per passenger is
set by the civil aviation or authority
Heathrow has been complaining that that
amount is too low and I think the fact
they're still making a loss does support
that perhaps their view is correct all
right Rachel got to leave it there good
to see you this morning thank you thank
you
going to break away momentarily from the
business news because the Home Secretary
Suella bravaman is speaking in central
London about Police recruitment we're
just going to have a quick listen in yes
side not pandering to politically
correct preoccupations it means
measuring the police on outputs such as
public response times crime solved and
criminals captured it means police
officers freed up to spend their time on
proper police work it means police
prioritizing the highest harm crimes and
those that matter most to the public it
means the police making use of powers
like stop and search that have proven
effective in taking weapons off our
streets and above all else Common Sense
policing means officers maintaining a
Relentless focus on fighting crime
catching criminals and keeping the
public safe
and I'm going to speak on each of those
items today
firstly the public wants to see more
Bobbies on the beat and so do I it is
Central to Common Sense policing
everyone who has been part of the
government's police uplift program
should be immensely proud of what we've
achieved in the last few years
many said we couldn't do it but this is
a police success a home office success
and a conservative government success
we've delivered an additional 20
951 officers into policing over the past
three years
there are now almost 150
000 police officers across England and
Wales the highest number ever
24 forces now have more police officers
than they ever had before the program
I'm extremely grateful to police Chiefs
for leading this drive and to those men
and women who've signed up you are now
part of a policing family epitomized by
bravery and dedicated to public service
and safety
as part of the new generation of
policing you will help to raise
standards refocus priorities and
maintain our world-leading place in
policing
policing must remain open to the best
and the bravest whether or not they have
a degree and Common Sense policing means
encouraging the recruitment of officers
that come from and live in the
communities they serve familiar with
local challenges
there you go if you want to carry on
watching Sue Ella bravman the Home
Secretary in uh hearing her speech on
Police recruitment you can do so by
scanning the QR code
right now
now Elite Network rail documents
recently suggested that delays on the I
think that's the wrong story let me come
to the next story Live Events have
bounced back since the end of covered
restrictions with some tours uh set like
that other comic Peter K selling out
more than two years in advance however
according to recent polling half of
Britain say they've been priced out of
going to see live music in recent years
undeterred by that the O2 is to open a
live exclusive VIP members club with a
300 person capacity at the venue
residence called the residence oh
joining me now to talk about this is
Paul Samuels he's Executive Vice
President at AEG Global Partnerships
Paul welcome to you well clearly uh
you're not worried about the cost of
living crisis uh we're seeing people
still come into Live Events we are
selling uh more shows than ever before
2022 was out 23 was our biggest year yet
and uh last year was our biggest year
and this year seems to be even bigger
than that how much are these memberships
going to costs the memberships will cost
fifteen thousand pounds a year this is
an Ultimate VIP experience you'll have
amazing views of the stage uh you'll
have a private restaurant you can use
there's there's going to be a floating
Champagne Bar cocktail bar but the bit
I'm most excited about is we're having a
walkway that will come out above the
crowd in the audience
um by nine meters where you'll be able
to have that ultimate selfie moment and
have a picture in front of the stage
before it retracts before the show
starts so it's a really great experience
for people to come to the venue and
you'll only be selling 300 of these
there's 300 of them they're going to
sell very quickly uh premium offerings
that the O2 are all sold out we have our
premium Suites we have our VIP licenses
so this is a new Venture for us but we
know the demand is there uh so we're
expecting to sell out very quickly and
are you targeting corporate customers
here or do you think some rich
individuals will buy these as well it
will be both we see it as individuals
that want to you know to have those but
also for businesses and also the SME
Market people that maybe can't use a
corporate or premium suite uh for you
know we have over 200 shows a year uh at
the venue so it's a lot of hospitality
so some people might prefer to have just
four seats for those 200 plus shows
typically What proportion of sales at
the venue do go to corporate buyers now
do you have a handle on that um it's a
it's a small percent in the overall side
I mean we're very keen to ensure that
the the O2 is open to everyone the
tickets all different price points are
available so everyone can enjoy the
experience when they're there are you
concerned about some of this polling
though that suggests people do feel
themselves being priced out of going to
Live Events we haven't seen that in
reality be that at our venues like the
O2 or our music festivals we have a
music festival called American Express
presents uh BST in High Park
um which uh happens in the summer and we
sell out of that very very quickly and
the premium piece also sells very
quickly but the price point has only
gone up by about three percent since
2019. so we've not seen that kind of
issue where people aren't buying tickets
what about uh inflation I mean it's
obviously uh the the topic of of the
year really I guess I mean where are you
seeing inflation most rampant in your
cost base of course you know the cost of
you know electricity to put on put on
shows you know puts out the cost of
putting on these shows but we've not
really seen it affect uh people coming
to The Venue buying tickets and spending
money uh in the venue people are still
spending money in fact uh people are
spending more and more than they have in
the past labor has had an issue for you
it was coming out of um out of out of
covid but now we've all settled down we
don't have any issues there at all one
of the big things that kept coming up
for me during covid we had a lot of
people on from the Live Events industry
and people saying well lighting
technicians sound uh Specialists that
they're dropping out of the industry has
that been an issue for you or are there
is there plenty of talent still out
there I I think we're back now to the to
the levels that we were pre- pandemic
thankfully
um so we don't have it as much of an
issue that and it was it was a worry of
course but we're now back to where it
should be all right Paul got to leave it
there appreciate you joining me today
thank you very much
now Elite Network rail documents
recently suggested that delays on the
railways will get worse over the next
five years so confidential presentation
seen last week by The Independent
Newspaper suggested current funding
levels are not enough for Network rail
to operate maintain and renew its tracks
Bridges and infrastructure the railways
were hit particularly hard by the
pandemic and passenger numbers remain 25
below pre-covered levels well joining me
now is Mark venables who's managing
director at Megabus and a former head of
the project management office at the
department for transport Mark welcome to
you now you're on The View that Network
rail fully deserves to have its budgets
cut I gather
I wouldn't quite go that's it that far
but I think certainly they they need to
be
um need to be taking the action that
they're taking uh it's in everybody's
interest that public transport is
attractive and affordable so it's right
that they focus in on on making cost
reductions wherever they can
um so that they can hopefully better
deliver uh reliability and an affordable
travel
um the other point I would make is that
it sometimes feels a bit scary when we
talk about the railway but potentially
scaling back but there are other public
transport Alternatives out there which
is
um which is clearly what what we offer
at Megabus and Scottish City Link in in
Scotland as well absolutely so uh what
are you uh what's your offer to
passengers right now how are you trying
to get them off the trains and onto the
coaches
well ideally we'll get them off out of
cars and into coaches rather than off to
the trades but
um but certainly uh it's an awful lot
cheaper to travel by coach and it's a
very similar product offering and by
that I mean
um it's it's scheduled so there's a
there's a set departure time there's a
set arrival time
um and and the fares are are let's say
even today between Bristol and London
you can travel for under five pounds
which is astonishingly cheap uh if you
look on a rail retail website you're
going to be paying 35 40 pounds for the
same
um between Glasgow and Edinburgh for
example we are every 15 minutes so it
really is just walk up and go
um that's every 15 minutes between the
the two biggest cities in Scotland and
we cover all of the UK all the big towns
and cities so and in terms of Journey
time yeah the train is usually a bit
quicker but not always and sometimes
there's very little in it so for example
again uh we have a service between Leeds
and Liverpool uh it's about 90 minutes
from 90 minutes and the Train's about
the same so there's there's very often
nothing in it so that yeah the
alternative I mean you mentioned the
breast still to London route there I
mean I I can't see how you can possibly
be quicker than the train not with these
interminable Road works up and down the
M4
well it drives a very very competent and
we have um a 24 7 control room so we
know what's going on and we know how to
minimize disruptions wherever they can
but it does happen that that can happen
on the railway as well though
um but yeah generally Bristol London the
Train's a bit quicker but again it
depends exactly where you want to go so
if you want to go get off um out of town
um at Bristol and you can get dropped
off at the University of West of England
for example or in London you don't
necessarily want to go to Paddington
when you get off the train at Paddington
you might then have to buy another
ticket or pay for a taxi or find some
other way of getting across to different
parts of of the city whereas
um the coach's Mega Bus go from Victoria
Coach Station
now your parent company Stagecoach of
course was taken over last year by DWS
infrastructure has that changed the way
that you're operating at all
it has a little Stagecoach are a
minority shareholder in in Megabus and
Scotty City Link um we're not fully
owned by them anymore so yeah it has
changed things a little
all right Mark I'm so sorry we're we're
pushed for time now because we've had a
few technical Gremlins hopefully see you
again in future thank you okay
now as we've been reporting more or less
daily food price inflation is at a
45-year high that's one of the number of
challenges faced by the sandwich and
coffee chain pretamonte which has also
been grappling with high labor costs and
changing working patterns that have
affected footfall in City centers well
today the company has announced it's
expanding its coffee subscription
loyalty scheme to cover food snacks and
some cold drinks joining me now to talk
about this is panicristo he's the chief
executive of prep panel welcome to you
what's the thinking behind expanding
this scheme
well I think uh once we launched the
positive subscription in 2020 it's been
a great success and our customers have
really loved uh the program I think the
average popular subscriber last year
saved the equivalent of 600 pounds so
about 50 pounds a month and uh we've
been thinking long and hard on what to
to invest in and I think moving to Club
prep which now has food discounts as
well on top of that so we see that the
average uh Club prep member this annual
savings will move from 600 pounds to 800
pounds uh you know we've had a lot of uh
challenges over the last year also as
many other companies have grown
inflation I've been very proud to see
what we've done in investing in our
people and we'll continue to do that but
I think what club prep does is really
acknowledges uh and thanks uh our
customers that have been so loyal to us
and for those that maybe want to join
the program you have a food discount as
well as up to 150 drinks a month yeah
now you are also we're raising the cost
of a monthly subscription from 25 to 30
pounds
yes we are
um but I think we still see this is
absolutely amazing value for money we
have seen food prices
um obviously as we've said we've
invested in our people and energy prices
continuing to grow but I think from our
perspective you know we're focused on
looking after our people and continuing
to invest in our people and then giving
our customers Great Value which we
believe Club prep will build on this
success of the coffee subscription now
we did get a bit of evidence yesterday
that uh grocery price inflation may have
peaked more broadly are you seeing that
yet with food and drink inflation
I'm not sure if it's peaked yet I think
it's still to see how it plays out you
know clearly uh food inflation has
continued to move and uh overall
inflation is stubbornly High
um I think that uh obviously government
support for energy costs uh have come
away this month uh so I think it'd be
really interesting to see what companies
do from our perspective I think we are
you know not passing on all the price
that we get we're trying to take on uh
and mitigate to the rest of our ability
we can't totally weather that but I
think we're wanting to ensure that we
give great value to our customers and I
think that's something we'll be focused
on well to that end what have you made
of these comments overnight from Hugh
pill the bank of England's Chief
Economist I mean he's basically said
people shouldn't ask for pay Rises and
companies shouldn't look to pass on
price increases
well I think you know from cret's
perspective we're focused on two things
number one is given uh our teams uh the
right pay to ensure they are looked
after during these challenging
environments and I think if you know the
inflation is high we will continue to
look after our people and ensure that
our people can live the lives that they
deserve to live and I think the other
Focus will be ensuring we've got great
value for our customers so obviously the
the government and Bank of England are
are are accountable for looking after
their inflation but from our perspective
you know our people and our customers is
what we will continue to look after and
over the last year we've given our staff
uh almost a 20 increase and I wouldn't
be surprised if we're having to come
back this year and do that again if
inflation stays where it is that's
really I mean so basically you're doing
exactly what uh Hugh pill doesn't want
you to do I think you've raised salaries
three times over the last year and
you're also putting up your prices
you're doing exactly what he doesn't
want people and companies to do
I I acknowledge you know his point of
view and I think that if inflation does
come down we will look to to to manage
things in in the way that we can into
the best of our ability but uh you know
I think our staff you know come in very
early in the morning work extremely hard
for us
foreign
looking after our people in in the right
way
um and supporting them through this
difficult time Hannah Before I Let You
Go you've just opened your first Outlet
in India is it too soon to say how
that's going
um it's it's uh it opens on Friday so
very excited with the opening it's been
a phenomenal success uh we have our
second location opening and why uh in
the next three to four weeks or so and
then we'll also be opening in Delhi
later this year so the the prep ground
seems to be translating well across the
world and I think India is an example of
that as well
all right Banner gotta leave it there
great to see you this morning thank you
thank you
now in 10 days from now I've had less
than that uh the coronation of his
majesty the king will take place at
Westminster Abbey and memorabilia and
souvenir sellers have been gearing up
among them is housing days founded in
1950 which specializes in English made
luxury goods in the form of enamelware
English find bone china enamel jewelry
and silk accessories well joining me now
is its chief executive Pamela Harper
Pamela good to see you this morning uh
you've linked launched five limited
edition collections to Mark the
coronation which one is selling best
right now
uh well there's there are two that are
doing very well indeed and if I may I'll
just show you if you see it
um this is um one which we call the
celebration of the natural world and
it's a celebration of all the things
that we know our King uh loves and
admires so the Flora and corner of the
British Isles
um and it's a wonderfully hand-drawn
piece
um and this has gone down very well I
think also because we have a charity
donation attached to the sales of this
uh particular range which is to the
princess Countryside fund which supports
rural communities across the UK so that
one has been very well received and then
at the other end of the scale
um this rather joyous and naive uh
depiction of Westminster Abbey with the
lovely Golden State coach arriving or in
fact we'll be departing uh with the king
and queen after the coronation this one
is doing really well because I think it
brings
um a sort of slightly beef but rather
fun uh approach to the coronation and of
course we're known for our very
traditional pieces but this one has done
very well also
Pablo you the first piece you held up
there has the King's new Cipher uh it
has it been released to the public that
long did you have enough time to
incorporate it into all the designs yeah
and you hit on it on on something that
was uh really difficult for us because
of course we started work on the
coronation collections last Autumn
um and I I can't remember the exact date
but I think it was the end of March when
the cycle was released and of course we
had all the product ready to receive the
cipher
um but it's been a Race Against Time
that absolutely has
um you know quality product does take
time to design to get all the raw
materials and then we started design
immediately we've stopped start started
building our whiteware as far back as as
October
um because we anticipated about an extra
150 000 pieces that we would need to
make to supply demand both the UK and
international for the coronation so it's
been a Race Against Time and it
absolutely has but we're shipping daily
and uh so far keeping our customers
happy and I gather correct me if I'm
wrong pamara I think all of your
production is now in the UK
it is and we're very very proud of that
we have two factories the one I'm
standing in which is our fine bone china
Factory in Stoke-on-Trent which is an
entirely handmade Factory we have
um 50 very highly skilled staff many of
whom have been with us for over 40 years
um and the skills involved in creating a
product of this quality are incredible
whether that's in the whiteware part of
the factory or in fact in the gilding
and decorating and then our second
Factory is in Wolverhampton where we
have our enamel Factory which of course
is the original Factory of Halcyon Days
the enamelware part of our business so
yes and we've been reassuring uh over
covid we didn't have a lot overseas but
we did have for example our silk made in
Italy we've reshold that into the UK and
some of our component parts where we
still were bringing in from uh in in
certain cases Vietnam we've actually
reassured everything so we're we're
about 93 percent in
I'm sorry Pamela good to see you this
morning thank you I'm back tomorrow
hopefully see you then Jane Tech is up
next